e
herkese Merhaba Hoş geldiniz ismi Mehmet
Toprak kayropraktik uzmanıyım eminim
birçoğunuz ilk defa duyuyor ne olduğu
hakkında birçok kimsenin fikir sahibi
olmayabileceği bir alan şimdi çok kısa
sürede başladı kendi Kaderinden
bahsedeceğim aslında bir insanın
kendisini anlatması Belki çok şık
olmayabilir ama konuşma başlığından
ilham vermesi açısından kendi konuşma
bastım Coğrafya kader değildir bunu
anlatmak istiyorum Hayat tercihlerden
ibarettir bildiğiniz gibi birçok kimse
Şu anda da lise öğrencisi olarak
birçok kimse Bugün bir karar verdi ve bu
konuşmaya gelmek istediğiniz şu anda
buradasınız ona da bu konuşma teklif
edildiği zaman ben de bir karar verdim
dedim ki ben burada olmalıyım ve bu
konuşmayı yapmalıyım bu hayat verdiğiniz
kararlardan ibarettir bazen kabul etmek
doğru seçenek olabilir bazen reddetmek
lise öğrencisiyken
buradaki birçok kimse gibi bende ne
olmak istediğim konusunda çok
kararsızdım birçok seçeneğiniz var
pilotluk Eczacılık öğretmenlik
Mühendislik kendinizi tanımaya
çalışıyorsunuz dünyayı tanımaya
çalışıyorsunuz beş sene sonrasında 20
sene sonrasında 30 sene sonrasını 17 18
yaşındayken öngörerek doğru seçeneği
doğru karar vermeye çalışıyorsunuz
aileniz bir yandan fikir veriyor ve
öğretmenlerin fikir veriyor
arkadaşlarınız Akrabalarınız herkes sizi
yönlendiriyor Ama doğru cevabı asla
Kimse bilmiyor
benim lisede okurken ne olacağına karar
verme sürecinde bir telefon etkili
olmuştu kuzenim Fizik Tedavi ve
Rehabilitasyon isimli bir programı
kazanmış annem de geldi dedi ki kuzeni
tebrik etmemiz gerekiyor Çünkü o bir
doktor yardımcı olacak dedi bana çok
garip geldi dedim Hanife ne haberin ne
olduğunu bilmiyorum ama bence dedim bu
doktor yardımcılığı değil Niye dedi
çünkü dedim o zaman bunun adı Doktor
yardımcılığı olurdu yani bu başka bir
şey olabilir Sonra kuzenimi tebrik etmek
için aradık bu bölümü anlattı zaman o
zamanlar yaygın değil bundan onbeş sene
öncesinden bahsediyorum benim hoşuma
gitti ve bölümü okumaya karar verdim
Tabi ki annem babam istemedi
arkadaşlarım hiç bir fikir sahibi değil
hatta öğretmenlerim de o dönem fikir
sahibi değil onlar da desteklemedi
bölümü tercih ettim ve bu benim
kariyerimi başlatan en önemli adım dış
ama her şey yolunda gitmedi bölüme
girdikten sonra aslında bana çok hitap
etmediğini çok sempati duymadığımı
birtakım kullanılan Çok etkili çok
faydalı ama benim açımdan Sıkıcı olan
cihazlarla ve egzersizlerle bu sürece
yönetildiğini fark edince Aslında
Moralim bozuldu ve çok doğru bir tercih
olmadığını düşündüm Ondan sonra bu
bölümün içerisinde mesleğin içerisinde
çok fazla uzmanlık alanı olduğunu ve iyi
bir uzmanlık alanı içerisinde kendimi
yetiştirsem seveceğim de bir branş
olursa başarılı olabileceğini düşünerek
Aslında arkadaşlarıma danıştım üstlenen
arkadaşlarıma ve dedim ki bana öyle bir
alan söyleyin ki bunu hem çok ihtiyaç
olsun Hem Bununla ilgili çok az yetişmiş
personel sağlık meslek mensubu olsun hem
de benim Sevebileceğim gelecek vadeden
bir şey olsun o zaman bana dediler ki
böyle ellerle yapılan birtakım tedaviler
var hepimiz biliriz görmüşüzdür birileri
birileri sırtına çıktı Atıyor işte yere
yatıyorsunuz sırta çıkıyor Kendi kendine
boynun sırtın çıktı ya onlar var bunun
Aslında bilimsel bir tedavi olduğunu
hata bir meslek olduğunu ama ülkemizde
yetişmiş eleman olmadığı için Anadolu'da
belli illerde belli işlerde Kırıkçı
Çıkıkçı ların şu anda elinde olan bir
branş olduğunu söylediler Benimde ilgimi
çekti Çünkü ilaç yok İyi ne yok ameliyat
yok oldukça organik faydalı bir şey ve
bu alanda yetişmiş insan yok günümüzde
de Herkes telefonla bilgisayarla her gün
daha fazla vakit geçirdiği için bel ve
boyun ağrıları daha sık görülecek
gelecekte maden bir branş O yüzden
branşı tercih etmeye karar verdim ve bir
Mentol ihtiyacım olduğunu düşündüm çünkü
Modern tıbbın babası Hipokrat Babası da
hekimde Tıp sektörü usta-çırak
ilişkisiyle gelişen bir sektör Ben çok
okuyarak sadece araştırma yaparak
kendini geliştiremez siniz çok kaba
Türkçesiyle birilerinden ele almanız
gerekir birlerini size mentörlük etmesi
gerekir ve bu konuda Türkiye'de kim
varsa araştırıp onlarla birlikte Ben de
bu alanda bu çalışmaya karar verdim
sonra öğrenci olarak o dönem sosyal
medya yok Instagram yok Facebook Türkçe
değil sanıyorum Dolayısıyla blog
sitelerinden bu tip ilaçları araştırdım
şöyle küçük bir kitapçık yaptım kendime
ve bu alanda çalışan herkesi tespit
ettim biyografilerini indirdim hangi
alanda çalışıyorlar köşe yazıları neler
neler yapıyorlar şeklinde ve 3-5 kişiyle
görüştüm O zaman ki öğrenci bütçem
paramı biriktiriyorum şehir dışına
çıkıyorum orada Konaklı yorum param
bitince geri geliyorum borç alıyorum
tekrar giriyorum Bu şekilde bir
koşturmaca ve bir kişiyi tespit ettim bu
kişi
bütün Uzmanlar arasında böyle Parlayan
Yıldız gibiydi dedim ki ben bu kişinin
yanında yetişirsem herhalde çok iyi
noktaya gelirim ve kendisine şöyle bir
mail attım dedim ki beni iki sene
kliniği al çalıştır istersen çok
toplarım istersen paspas atarım ne
istiyorsan yaparım Yeter ki beni al ve
yetiştik Çünkü bu alanda çok fazla kimse
yok Ve ben bunu öğrenmek istiyorum ok
işte kabul etti beni mentorum olarak bu
yolculuk o birkaç ay geçti samimi olduk
abi kardeş olduk yakın görüşüyoruz böyle
çok beni tatmin etmeyen bir şeyler
olduğunu fark ettim örnek veriyorum
kuyruk sokumu kemiğini Herkes bilir
omurgamızın en altındaki kemiktir onun
Latincesi foxxtor Mesela ben koksiks
ilgili bir soru sordum zaman o bana
pöçük kemiği diye yanıt veriyordu küçük
kemiği öztürkçe değil Daha çok iç
Anadolu'dan kullanılan bir tabir ben de
pek bilmiyorum O bana söylüyor Ben ona
söylüyorum ortada buluşmaya çalışıyoruz
bir gün dedim ki neden bu şekilde
terminolojiden uzak konuşuyorsun dedi ki
Ben küçükken Doktora gittim doktor bana
bu çocuk Faranjit oldu dedi ve 3 gece
ağladım faranjiti çok kötü bir hastalık
sandım ve bunun önemli bir şey
olmadığını fark ettikten sonra bir daha
latinceye meslektaşlarıma ve hastalığına
karşı kullanmama kararı aldım ama
esasında anadili gibi doğru sürece
vakfın diyecek Ben bir kez daha
etkilendim Tabi ki bir süre sonra biraz
daha samimi olduk ve O kendisi bana
kapıyı kapat dedi Sana bir sır vereceğim
dedi bu kişi ana haber bültenlerine
çıkan Türkiye'nin en ünlü en Saygın
klise yanlarından bir tanesi
bende de makine mühendisliği takip
Aslında lise mezunuyum dedi ben ta
başından aşağı kaynar sular döküldü
kendi olmak istediğim noktada Türkiye'de
zirvede görülen kişinin böyle bir
durumda olduğunu öğrenince dedim
Coğrafya kaderdir nereye gidiyoruz Ne
oluyor Ne yapacağım dedim çıktım oradan
a doğrusu çıkmadan önce şunu söyledim
Dedim ki sen bir şeyler yapıyorsun dedim
ya lise mezunu da olsan bir protokole
göre belli işlemler yapıyorsun bu nedir
dedim O da bana dedi ki kayropraktik
denilen bir şey var ben üç ay bir
kayropraktik ofisinde bulundum dedi
orada çok mu topladığı telefonun baktığı
Çay mı yaptı Detay yok ben de oradan
çıktım dedim ki bu adam Suyunun suyu
sabuk aynı taktikleri çok güzel bir şey
Çok etkili bir şey olmadı ben gideyim
gerçek bir kayropraktik bulayım ve onun
yolundan ilerleyin E tabii ki her gencin
karşılaştığı acı gerçekle karşılaştım
bunun eğitimini en iyi Amerika'da
veriliyor ve birkaç yüz bin dolar eğitim
bütçesi gerekiyor Yani Tıp Fakültesi'ni
fizyoterapi bitiriyorsunuz gidiyorsunuz
dört yıl ekstra ve eğitim oluyorsunuz
büyük maliyetler Ben öğretmen çocuğum
böyle bir aile bütçem yok ve ama
kariyerimde yapmak istediğim birşey
önündeki seçenek var ya vazgeçeceğim ya
para bulacağım ve kısa bir süre
içerisinde bulmam gerekiyor Ondan sonra
dedim ki o zaman ben bir yerlerden bu
parayı temin etmeye çalışacağım
araştırdım ettim derken bir iş insanı
buldum ismi Alphan Manas burada İslam
belki tanımıyor olabilirsiniz ama
iddiayı kupon olarak doldurulan iddiayı
Türkiye'ye getiren Türkiye fütüristler
Derneği Onursal Başkanı çok Saygın bir
iş insanı kendisine bir üniversite
öğrencisi olarak mail attım dedim ki
Altan Bey merhabalar köşe yazınızı
okudum Siz bu mesleğe bu branşa dair çok
fazla sempati duyuyor musunuz ne mutlu
ki ben de duyuyorum o eve sizden
yalnızca birkaç üzüm dolayı istiyorum
ben bunun eğitimini alacağım Bunun
karşılığında Umuyorum ki eğitim
bittikten sonra Türkiye dönmeye karar
veririm ve gelirsen burada klinik açarız
kazandığım paranın üç yılda yeşil
oyununda ise yarısını size veririm Hem
bu alanı Türkiye'de bilimsel temelleri
otururuz hem ben bunu Okurum Hem siz
para kazanırsınız gibi ticaretten
oldukça Mantıksız bir mail attım
Hatta kuzenim yanımdaydı o dedik ya
adama yazık dedi buna önemli insanlar
hani 3 Dakikasını ayıracak da dedi bu
neyli okuyacak en dönme ihtimali zaten
yok Niye böyle bir şey yapıyorsun dedi
Ben de dedim ki ya dönerse Nasrettin
Hoca hikayeleri bilirsiniz Tabi ki Altan
Bey bana bu parayı vermedin şaşırtıcı
bir sonuç yok ama bana oltayı gösterdi
dedi ki bu alandan mezun olan ve bununla
ilgili çalışmalar yürüten kişiler var
bunlarla temas kurabilirsin Benim de
selamımı ilet iletişimleri Bunlar sonra
ben bu kişiler ulaştım üniversite
öğrencisi bu arada O kim ki ben bunu
olmak istiyorum siz bunu olmuşsunuz Ama
bende para yok bunu nasıl yapacağız
dediler ki birkaç seçeneği var ve
yurtdışına gideceksin fizyoterapist
olarak orada çalışırken part-time
okuyacaksın ya da biz bunu Türkiye'de
Akademik olarak bir üniversitede
uzmanlık olarak eğitimi başlatmaya
çalışıyoruz Ama üniversite Networking
yok Türkiye'de çok insan kaynağı kimseyi
tanımıyoruz süreç yönetimlerini
bilmiyoruz Bu konuda bize yardımcı
olursan bunu Türkiye'de eğitimli
başlatır Sen de bunu Bedensiz
diyebileceğimiz çok cüzi paraları
okursun Ben de dedim ki ya ben evde
PlayStation oyuncak geldim üniversite 3.
sınıf öğrencisiyim siz bana fakülte
kurmayı öneriyorsunuz herhalde dedim
tamam anlaşamadık doğru şeyi ile Doğru
iletişim kurma olabilir hayır dediler 18
yaşından büyük misin Evet sen Bir
yetişkin bireysin orta ki değerlerimiz
var kimlerle Network olabilir kimde ne
Azim olabilir Bunlar belli olmaz bize
katkıda bulunmak istiyorsan birlikte
bunu yapalım dediler hem de tamam dedim
Ondan sonra
da ve ve üniversiteden mezun oldum
Bahçeşehir ve araştırma görevlisi olarak
göreve başladım Sonra akademisyen olarak
bir yandan çalışmalar yaparken bir
yandan da üniversite mi böyle bir Rush
olduğunu bunun eğitimini Türkiye'de
başlaması gerektiğini çok önemli
olduğunu Dünyada sadece 17 ülkede
olduğunu ve Türkiye'de başlarsa bunun
sağlık sistemi açısından da gereksiz
ameliyatlar gereksiz ilaç masrafları
enjeksiyonlar bunlara karşı değiliz ama
gerektiği takdirde kullanılması için
sağlık sistemine de çok büyük
maliyetlerle efektif olarak faydalı bir
şey olduğunu anlattım ve üniversite ikna
oldu
Onu Bahçeşehir Üniversitesi'nde 2015
yılında bana bir Görev verildi Bendeki O
zaman sen bunu Yüksek Lisans Programı
olarak hazırla biz sen at olarak en süt
olarak bunu kabul ediyoruz tam olarak
telaffuz etmekte zorlanıyoruz
kayropraktik bir şeyler bir şeyler ama
bunun faydalı bir şey olduğuna ikna
olduk o yüzden biz sana bu görevi
veriyoruz otur dosya hazırlanıyor
Onaylıyorum dendi ve ben üniversitede üç
ay boyunca bir oda ya kapa o kimse bana
karışmadı dünyadaki farklı kıtalarda ki
Avrupa Amerika Avustralya'daki çok
önemli üniversiteleri müfredatları
çıkardım ve bir eğitim programı yazdık
bunu Yok ya Gönderdik ve gökten
Onayınızı aldık Dolayısıyla 2015 yılında
Türkiye'de ilk defa bunun yüksek lisans
programı başladı Bende nacizane Tüm
Türkiye'de en genç yaşlı bir yüksek
lisans burs programı kurucusu olmuş
bulundum Hatta belki de Dünyada bilinen
en gençler olabilir programı okudum
bitirdim Daha sonra da bana dediler ki
bunun başına geçmeni istiyoruz yine en
genç yaşta bir yüksek lisans programının
Bölüm Başkanı olarak çalışmalar yaptık
ve bu dünya meslek örgütleri arasında
çok büyük Yankı uyandırdı gittiğimiz
bütün toplantılarda bizi onur konuğu
olarak kabul ettiler üniversite
öğrencilerimize bu tip uygulamalı omurga
sağlığı ile ilgili eğitimler veriyoruz
Burası Norveç'te Nobel ödüllerinin Nobel
Barış Ödülleri verildiği salon 5 bir
taktik uzmanının dünyanın 90 farklı
ülkesinden giden uzmanın olduğu bir fong
r2016 yılı ve orada Türkiye'deki Türkiye
Aslında 18 ülke olarak dünyada bunun
akademik eğitimin başladığı ülkede
Türkiye'de başlamış henüz Almanya'da He
bunun Akademik eğitim yok Nasıl
başlattınız ne oldu bakanlık nasıl ikna
oldu Üniversite nasıl ikna olduğu
Yükseköğretim kuruluna 86 nasıl
başlattınız diye burada röportajlar
verdik ve
ne demek işlerimiz alındı Daha
sonrasında bu da
2018yılı İngiltere'de tüm Avrupa'daki
kayropraktik eğitimlerin verildiği
üniversitelerin davet edildiği bir
akreditasyon toplantısı burada her
üniversite kendi müfredatını paylaşıyor
kendi deneyimlerini paylaşıyor ve bütün
Avrupa'da Akademik eğitim standardını
Mesleğiniz için yükseltmeye
çalışıyorsunuz yine
Avrupa'da mesleğe dair üniversitemiz
adına katkılarda bulunmaya çalıştık
günümüzde şu anda
2015 yılında başlayan program 2017
yılında ilk mezunlarını verdi Her yıl
onlarca fizyoterapistle Hekim bu
programdan Türkiye Cumhuriyeti'nde mezun
olmakta Türkiye şu anda 18 ülke
içerisinde yer alıyor ve bu programda
yazılan tezler uluslararası olarak
makale dönüştürülüyor yayınlanıyor
Örneğin benim yazdığım tezlerden ortaya
çıkan uluslararası makaleler dünyada
özgül ağırlık olarak bir skala var fiyat
whiteson ve içindeki diye geçer bu
indekse göre benim akademik puanım tüm
dünya akademisyenleri arasında dört kat
ortalamanın 4 kat üzerinde kendi
Bahçeşehir Üniversitesi'nde tüm Sağlık
Bilimleri fakültesinde onlarca
akademisyen arasında en yüksek puan son
beş yılın ortalamasına bakılıyor Çünkü
henüz Türkiye'de Avrupa'da ve dünyada
bilimsel temelleri tam olarak oturmamış
tam olarak kökleşmiş bir bilim dalı
üzerine çalışma yürütüyor sanız
yaptığınız yayınlar çalışmalar tüm dünya
tarafından Saygın olarak kabul ediliyor
üniversitenizin dünya sıralaması bu
yayınlarla daha yüksek sıralamaya
geliyor Dolayısıyla üniversite de bu
alanda bizim tamamen arkamızda teşvik
ediyor Hatta başka üniversitelerde şu
anda bu yüksek lisans programını kurmaya
başladılar Türkiye'deki üniversitede var
her yıl on binlerce hasta sadece benim
kalbimde 5000 hasta birçok meslektaşım
kliniğinden on binlerce hasta bu
eğitimden bu tedaviden faydalanıyor
Dolayısıyla baktığınız zaman Aslında
benim yeter bu işlemden dolayı yola
çıktım bir süreçte Ama birçok meslektaş
birçok hastanın fayda görmesine yol açan
ve bir anabilim dalı kurulmasına kadar
uzanan bir kariyer yolculuğu du O yüzden
coğrafya kadar değildir diyoruz e